[Music]
so I hope you enjoy that this week I
spent some time listening to ragtime
music and this is what I came up with
obviously I stuck with the mini keyboard
so the range limitation was definitely a
challenge but it was fun to do some of
the things that I took note of while
getting to know the music of this genre
a bit more is that the perkiness of the
rhythm comes from the combination of the
constant left-hand pattern along with
the syncopated right hand in general
okay it's getting too loud here
the left hand generally strides between
bass notes and chords in the middle
register and the right hand usually
carries a single melodic line or a
mixture of lines and intervals
or octaves that add syncopated stabs
that adds to the jagged time feel and
this is especially characteristic of the
type of sound I associate ragtime music
with
[Music]
so most of these works were fully
compose and written out especially in
the turn of the 20th century which is
why I think a lot of classical musicians
even today are still being exposed to
ragtime and as the music developed its
stride piano from my understanding a lot
more improvisation than the complexity
harmonic complexity tempo shifts things
like that were added and perhaps that is
a topic for another video but for now I
enjoyed making this one thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye
[Music]